un hospital local está realizando una
rifa para colectar fondos
el costo individual de participar en la
rifa está dado por la siguiente
expresión cinco temas tres o cinco por
temas tres donde te representa el número
de boletos que la persona adquiere
evalúa la expresión cuando te es igual a
1 t es igual a 8 y t es igual a 10 bien
consideremos primero cuando te cuando te
es igual a 1 entonces esta expresión de
aquí resulta en y luego a poner el mismo
color 5 por t que es igual a 15 por 1 +
35 por uno más tres y sabemos que en el
orden de las operaciones se hace primero
la multiplicación antes de la suma así
es que cinco por uno es igual a 5 más
353 esto es claramente igual a 8 hagamos
ahora cuando te es igual a 8
cuando t es igual a 8 esta expresión se
traduce en
5 y voy a usar el mismo color 5 por 8 5
por 8 más usó el mismo verde más 3 y
esto va a ser igual al 5 por 8 es 40
+ 3 y esto es igual a 43 hagamos el
último caso cuando te iguala 10 y lo voy
a hacer en azul lo voy a hacer en azul
así que tenemos que te es igual a 10 por
lo que 5 te es 5 por 10 en lugar de
latte ponemos 10 5 por 10 más 35 por 10
más 3 ese es un tono distinto de verde
pero bueno lo importante es la idea 5 x
1050 ya eso le tenemos que sumar 3 y eso
es igual a 53 y así hemos concluido